technology gets a lot of flack these
days yet as the futurist Ray Kurzweil
has said before technology is also the
only thing that has ever helped us
overcome problems right we use our tools
to extend our range of possibilities we
use our tools to extend our reach to
extend the impact about consciousness to
extend our will right technology is the
human imagination turned inside out
now the futurists and writers Andy Clark
and David Chalmers have used the term
skinbag bias to explain this aversion to
man-made technology we seem to assume
that everything that's natural is within
our skin tissue and everything that we
make in the world is somehow artificial
but this duality for friends is an
illusion you really want to think of the
things of man we have to think of the
things of mind our technology is a
scaffolding of our mind it extends our
mind and our agency in a very real way
that might as well be called anatomical
if you drew the vie true vien man today
you might put a smartphone in his hand
and point to it with a diagram as if it
was literally a part of its Anatomy we
are distributed beings we have
distributed our mindedness across the
planet like a cloak and even into
Otherworld we traverse the surface of
today with a rover that is nothing but
embodied lined on wheels my friends we
use tools to extend our reach we build
the tools the tools build us we build
new tools those tools builds us this
runaway train before we know it will
allow us to literally spread ourselves
throughout the universe our capacity to
create these virtual models in our heads
and then build them in the world was
sufficient along with our modest-looking
thumbs to create a secondary force of
evolution my friends we are self
creating species and this technology in
this core evolution between us and our
tools will continue until we universe is
that fingertips some call it a project
of singularity some call it
transcendence perhaps perhaps religion
was just a rehearsal for our own
ambition perhaps we sought to use
engineering to create nirvana for
ourselves
perhaps our omnipotent desires for total
communion with the cosmos our noble
indeed and because we are the technology
creating species my friends we should
not stand in our own way we are smack in
the middle between the born and the made
we are as gods as Stuart brand said and
might as well get good at it so go
innovate go dream bigger than ever
before
you